probably Magnus maybe Magnus how do we
sing I like to solve my life with one
chick's life just to see and my dog just
to see you know how it feels to be
always happy if you could be a
professional athlete in any other sport
which would it be today it will be
tennis or badminton maybe table tennis I
like table tennis probably a cricketer
because ice skating basketball I really
love basketball basketball if you're a
good Master any musical instrument
immediately what wouldn't be the drums
okay we had to say pianos I am also
going with that
novel guitar excellent or violin what's
your go-to karaoke song
I mean I enjoy listening to music but I
don't want to spoil it with my my
singings but I only sing in the shower
or when nobody can hear me they're too
good uh with reactions
if you could eat only one food item for
the rest of your life easy chicken and
rice fried rice
what's your favorite video game
smash gross melee NHL 97 civilization
final question you can't be diplomatic
here to be honest if you could remove
one team from Global Chesney which would
it be and why maybe truly it would be
trivia because I don't have any Indian
player
why is everyone after three minutes
which is the same because they are very
close sentence so we have to remove the
Alpine because we want to win the sun I
think I will not remove himself but